quoi
[Musique]
le grand concours je vous pose des
questions si vous répondez mal bien sûr
ça se passera mal qu'elle proche de
benjamin castaldi présentait une
émission nice people en duo avec arthur
en 2003 sûreté est fort possible qu'elle
proche de benjamin castaldi présentait
nice people sur tf1
allez moi c'était même qu'alex
[Musique]
au sein de ce corps est le temple est
qu'à l'émission de sport est à l'antenne
de tf1 depuis près de 40 ans le dimanche
téléfoot réponse vrai ou faux
le prénom d'eric zemmour et rasheed
wallace en a quelle émission animée par
laurent ruquier ne resta qu'une semaine
à l'antenne de tf1 en 1995
s'il est ouvrier ville
[Musique]
vrai ou faux
non c'est pas ça dans quelle émission de
télé réalité at on découvert pour la
première fois karine ferri stationnaire
da silva l'été
havas est reparti
toujours rage et la bouche ouverts quel
est le nom de famille d'hélène dans
hélène et les garçons facile c'est avec
sa paye son père monsieur à son père bah
oui madame cissé son père il à s'aimer
club d'annezin
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
valérie bénaïm bernard millet le cousin
d'hervé mathoux
[Rires]
si on n'est pas la communauté
avec quel blonde nikos aliagas était
présentée la première saison de the
voice avec l blanche the voice flavie en
2001 tient avec kg hana avait-elle
remporté la première édition de loft
story il reste confiant et j'en ai fait
un nom vous dit qu'est ce que vous dites
vous
[Musique]
tous les jours